okay is that big enough for you to sing
can you guys see that you make it out
see you can see here i picked up the
woman are not by accident right a
thermometer is a perfect example where
you've got numbers that go up it's like
it's getting hotter and hotter and
you've got numbers that go down as well
it's getting colder and colder and
colder this is the Celsius scale write
the web very fluid and like I said zero
degrees right in there that's the
freezing point okay now what I would
actually like you to do is after we're
done here discuss here I wouldn't want
you to copy this into your book so you
can see this idea of the number line and
going up and down right this above bore
idea think that this is not a
complicated we've met this idea before
we talked at temperatures who's lit to
somewhere really cold before hands up
who's this who reckons there's it in the
coldest place can pretty colder than
anyone in this room here I guess Cameron
where are you where'd you live that was
called are you stretching new
restrictions someone who live something
fall anywhere did you didn't tell me
okay let's come and look at that the
same ready Rachel either small- 11-11 s
wait idea was that after us tonight
japan japan can get pretty call it snows
can someone beat minus eleven anyone
yeah Charlie I mean yeah yeah we're pop
or was it obably minus 30 or minus 30 or
40 that's incredible
yeah yeah it's beautiful weather bit Oh
Eric movie that gentleman that's ok just
tell us what coldest ever had yet how
cold was it there yeah you know what
pretty cold um Christian one more yep
haha how cold was it it was stoic it was
cold enough to snow I had a friend had
one come to your example in a minute I
had a French who went to Russia and he
was always right on the Arctic Circle
and he said I said how calm oz is either
the number but it was good we call it
speaking temperature said what does that
mean speaking to me up and he says I
spit and on the way down the water
freezes and you can kick it by said
that's really gross but also really
really cold ok that's way down here on
the scale ok that is Jeb one more exam
be gentlemen yeah yeah Mountains I'm
very very complex yes my classmates
okay now hey there too I'll wait for
your attention 7m ok so this concept
positive Megan arms not complicated
let's have a look at a little bit and
see if we can ask these questions we can
work with these numbers and just watch
though they are and what temperature
does water boil you guys probably know
without even look at the graph at the
line what temperature water boys are
British very good I'm not reading them
wrong I get water boils tegan when doing
your first question together you're
welcome 1a I'm reading off the graph now
right this is not complicated one egg
100 degrees i'm just measuring their off
around 37 degrees what's measured at 37
what's important about 37 degrees yeah
buddy it's why you temperature at least
body temperature if you're alive okay so
where will mudded we keep our core
temperature the same temperature all the
time on my cold blood okay so Part B and
reading off that's body temperature
estimate the temperature and it says
estimate because we're try to read as
accurately as we can and which dry ice
evaporates who's seen dry ice before
like that's nothing source mall is it
very good ok have a look look at the
graph their way down here what's it
between have a look at the two marks is
between which to Marxism in between yeah
it's between now mark that its weight
below zero right so in fact it's minus
70 Celsius and minus 80 do you see that
what do you guys reckon is a closer to
my to send me on Monday I think it's
pretty much closer to minus 70 it's
pretty close to the middle maybe
slightest 7
3-7 well that's okay it's just an
estimate what's better than zero we
already pointed this one out 10 zoomin
someone shout it out its freezing point
very good last week this our last one we
can walk out together it was 48 degrees
in Algeria Africa and minus sixty nine
Nancy's might add in South Pole what was
the difference okay they remember how I
said I would like you to in a minute
draw this if you have it already started
okay when I'm trying to work out a
difference when I'm trying to work out a
difference if I say what's the
difference between 20 and 30 right
Charlie you can work you can work thank
you when I say the difference between 20
and 30 what I really need is how far are
20 and 30 apart right and you can see
we're tweeting they are an hour and that
difference of course is 10 degrees
Celsius right so if I want to know the
difference between 48 and negative 69 I
want to know well how far up do i have
to go and how far down where would you
put them on this graph 48 where's it
going to go off to it's about there
isn't it do you see that above body
temperature so I'm going to put them on
yeah and negative 60 knows all the way
right down there quite close to air dry
ice ax backwards right so I'm going to
put the mark there okay now on your
number line on your graph I want you to
show these two and sure the difference
cuz I'm about to do a hit of working
here which I want you to have on your
page as well okay if I don't work out
that whole distance the whole distance
what these numbers signifies that from
zero up to that really hot temperature
in Algeria that's 48 degrees right
48 degrees that's going up but this may
give secure what it indicates is it's
the same distance but down right so this
goes down 68 degrees so if I want to
know this distance the difference
between the two what am I going to do
with these two notice how am I going to
combine them i'm going to add them okay
that will give me the total distance
yeah 48 and 69 together so in fact I
need some working here this is question
one Part B and just like always we want
to describe just like with angles when
we're talking about reasons right I want
to describe this so I'm going to say
difference equals rather than just
writing down a number and say like what
does this number come from okay the
difference is i'm going to add those two
together 48 + 69 and that's going to be
the difference in degrees okay can we do
this in our heads are coming to visit
Santa heads Carly how would you do this
yeah web before you tell me the answer
question how would you do this in your
head what's a nice easy way we can work
with these numbers so I give me suggest
a great on the bus o + 8 okay so you can
do eight nine which is 17 and then you
can do your six of 16 plus 40 and 60
which is 100 right sir 117 perfect okay
now will point out this is a temperature
right so let's not forget to include
housing units them so this idea of
integers it's new but it's not that new
right like we've met temperatures before
we've heard these ideas this is where it
begins doing these computations it's
very very simple to begin with we're
going to explain this as we go further
into this topic so you've just done the
first question